[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv 78 merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau numéro de sion
rentrée comme chaque semaine nous allons
vous accompagner durant cette période de
post confinement de couvre-feu
dorénavant voici le sommaire noël ce
sera dans quelques jours maintenant et
qui dit noël dit film de noël vous avez
tout 16 et tous vos préférences dans un
instant nous vous livrons notre
sélection c'est le nouveau chef
pâtissier de la durée il réside dans les
yvelines
nicolas halloween ne nous a préparé un
dessert remarquable pour un repas de
fête et puis après ce petit écart
gastronomique il faudra tout de même
rester en forme en attendant le
déconfinement total enfants démission
quelques exercices à réaliser chez vous
grâce à notre coach sportif
[Musique]
elles étaient les films et les films de
noël sont depuis quelques semaines déjà
à la fiche d après-midi du petit écran
les plateformes de streaming bien
évidemment surf aussi sur cette vague
bonjour célia 10 nous pourquoi ces films
de noël et téléfilms de noël sont autant
à la mode
la pluie qui tombe un chocolat chaud à
la main enroulé dans un groupe led et et
bien sûr un bon film de noël de nombreux
yvelinois apprécient ce genre d'après
midi ou de soirée avait juste avant les
fêtes de fin d'année et de quoi et bien
anticipé la magie de noël
c'est l'esprit de noël c'est c'est plein
de bonheur les gens sont contents le
dîner de famille et cadeaux et c'est une
fois par an donc on en profite mois de
décembre c'est l'ambiance que ça crée
l'ambiance que ça suscite ça mais dans
onze mois justement l'ambiance qu'il ya
donc un peu chaleureuse familiale
à donner envie de regarder c'est plutôt
positif
après une année difficile comme celle là
alors malheureusement les cinémas sont
fermés mais les télés télévision et
plateforme de streaming dont qui sont
mis aussi et depuis quelques semaines
déjà
oui dès le 2 novembre alors soit
quasiment un mois al avance
le scénario est quasiment toujours le
même un personnage d'une grande ville
est de passage dans une petite ville qui
porte les valeurs de noël
et puis souvent se mêle une histoire
d'amour et c'est souvent plusieurs fois
par jour que certains sont proposés 6,77
téléfilm de noël ont été diffusés en une
foule mais tous regardés non je la ferme
votre wii et les audiences sont là alors
bien sûr le confinement est passée par
là mais en fait les téléfilms de noël
ont un large public
ils plaisent aussi bien aux jeunes
qu'aux seniors et puis les plateformes
donc de streaming s'y mettent aussi
netflix amazon prime disney plus tous
proposent leurs créations originales et
en tant que spécialiste vous avez
forcément des conseils à nous donner oui
alors demandons d'abord aux yvelinois
quelle est leur film de noël préféré
l'étrange noël de monsieur scrooge un
noël de princesse le grinch c'est
vraiment un film classique
alors oui le grinch c'est le film de
noël le plus populaire d'ailleurs un
remake est sorti en 2018 c'est une
créature en fait pour résumer qui
déteste noël et veut gâcher cette fête
en volant tous les cadeaux mais
finalement il va se rendre compte que
l'esprit de noël ne se résume pas à ça
bouge tout le tic dans leurs pairs
et dans d'autres styles vous avez
l'étrange noël de monsieur jack
joyeux noël ou encore klaus et dans et
d'autres plus connus et moins récents
maman j'ai raté l'avion ou encore le
célèbre film que je français qui revient
chaque année c'est le père noël est une
ordure pierre grimm une société qui se
déroule à noël on n'en paraît avant
cette émission faut pas oublier celui ci
dans un style un peu différent également
votre coup de coeur alors n'ont rien à
voir avec les gamines selon le greffe
nos films préférés restent love actually
alors oui mais c'est un film culte
réalisé par richard curtis film sorti en
2003 mais le dise histoire d'amour entre
romance des illusions rencontres
inattendues
le tout dans une ambiance de noël un
love actually a été diffusée sur m6 ce
jeudi dernier jeudi 10 décembre et à
rassembler encore plus de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs
et pour ceux qui ne l'auraient pas vu il
est encore disponible sur netflix et
amazon prime ce qu'il faudrait leur voir
et le revoir et la roma encore en
général voilà ça fonctionne comme ça
merci célia avant de poursuivre cette
émission un petit clin d'oeil à présent
à une entreprise insolite voilerie
atelier couture entreprises basé à
elancourt qui propose des accessoires
sacoche chaque ado au portefeuille a
fabriqué à la main à partir de voiles de
bateau une idée de cadeau pour noël avec
des modèles uniques s est à découvrir
sur internet sur les réseaux sociaux
aussi puisque la situation sanitaire
empêche cette entreprise de participer
au marché de noël
la fondatrice de ce concept maître
voilier sera ravie en tout cas de vous
accueillir même virtuellement pour
passer commande
la voilerie vous présente un produit
phare donc rouge mais il ya d'autres
couleurs il ya du blanc du bleu du gris
donc c'est des tissus un peu particulier
c'est un peu pour le tra le trampoline
de catamarans donc c'est des trousses de
toilette pour les garçons ou pour les
filles
donc c'est fait avec du fil voile 1.61
qui font toujours que le fil soit soit
visible
en termes de par rapport au noir ça soit
du blanc ou du rouge voilà on ne cache
pas les coutures en voilerie surtout pas
donc la partie noire ça s'appelle du 30
du dollar à l'img c'est ce qui bordent
les voiles tout simplement
et puis les ayez toujours une inox avec
des petites dents donc s'enlève jamais
voilà donc ça c'est un produit phare de
la voilerie et ce n'est pas parce que
nous serons moins nombreux à table qu'il
ne faudra pas se faire plaisir
bonjour et le nord vous allez nous
raconter votre rencontre avec un chef
pâtissier exactement noël approche à
grands pas vous l'avez dit du coup nous
sommes allés à la rencontre du chef
nicolas hâle irwin chef pâtissier
évidemment qui tient l'atelier gâteau à
guyancourt avec nicolas landry il nous
présente sa recette de tarte vanille
noix de pécan qu'il a revisité comme du
ch on retrouve en fait tous les éléments
forts de la tarte
on a créé cette année mais déclinées en
obus voilà donc en fait on a un biscuits
imbibés dans un bus à la vanille
d'ailleurs très vanier vanille bourbon
de madagascar avec une crème panna cotta
c'est une sorte de panacotta allégé
comme une chantilly
et un coeur coulant de praliné praliné à
la noix de pécan donc texture est légère
et ultra vomit et maintenant que nous
avons l'eau à la bouche comment se
réalise cette bûche et ben cjb le chef
la bo de l'atelier gâteau qui va nous
l'expliquer on va commencer par un vive
et de biscuits donc sur cette étape loeb
faut être généreux mais il faut pas
détrempé le biscuit ceux ci ont des 30
le biscuit on aura du mal à rouler
[Musique]
après avoir un bébé le biscuit donc il
faut cocher la panna cotta à la vanille
sur le biscuit ce potage donc
ah oui d'abord si on ne sait pas faire
de panna cotta on peut bien sûr pas
d'inquiétude on peut bien sûr le
remplacer par de la chantilly ou bien du
mascarpone et donc le chef nous
conseille d'utiliser une poche à douille
qui se nomme chemin de fer pour ceux qui
connaissent mais si on n'a pas ça à la
maison pas d'inquiétude non plus on peut
utiliser une grande cuillère
il faut laisser une petite bande libre
toutefois à la fin tout sur le biscuit
et on passe à l'étape notre paix quand
exactement origine j'ai bien suivi la
recette c'est ça on va pouvoir passer
aux pécan up qui vont apporter le
croustillant et une légère amertume
parce que la paix quand c'est légèrement
amer là on dispose comme on veut le tout
c'est d'être régulier pour que la
personne qui mange la bouche de ce côté
là où de ce côté là est plus ou moins la
même sensation après avoir disposé les
me paie quand on passe ensuite à la
dernière étape juste avant le roulage de
la biche
le chef insère le praliné paix quand
donc ces de la crème et du praliné
mélanger et ce mélange doit apporter le
sucre et l'onctuosité et le coeur
coulant ce coeur coulant c'est la petite
surprise dans l'anus et qu'il faut
maintenant rouler non il va l'étape
cruciale on va rouler la bûche l'appui
on va travailler sur des bûches qui sont
roulés donc pour avoir un côté
traditionnel et sûr des goûts qui sont
pas du tout traditionnel up
donc on est vraiment sur un aspect de
buch clover mais avec tout notre savoir
faire et tout notre gourmandise
voilà bus est maintenant terminée on
peut la décorer un peu comme on le
souhaite le chef lui il a entouré d'un
glaçage au chocolat blanc avec quelques
décors supplémentaire pour un peu de
croustillant et huila parsemé d'éclats
de noix de pécan inapte il n'y a plus
qu'à se régaler wilfried salaire assez
facile mais si on n'est pas très doué
tout de même pour la pâtisserie est un
site internet on peut commander
on peut aller commander en ligne et la
commande est justement chez chef nicolas
les ateliers gâteau gâteau avec un haut
point comme voilà pour le site internet
merci eléonore même si vous n'avez pas
ramené cette bûche en plateau et nous
culture à présent mais à domicile
forcément toujours l'office de tourisme
de saint germain boucles de seine a
débuté une série de vidéos dans les
coulisses des théâtres musées salles de
spectacles encore restaurant le but de
cette initiative soutenir le secteur de
la culture de la gastronomie également
en mettant en lumière les acteurs locaux
faire découvrir aussi l'agglomération la
de saint germain il ya eu de hashtag de
créée pour cette occasion
derrière le rideau et puis derrière les
fourneaux à on a été dans les réserves
d'un musée d'archéologie nationale et
dans les sous sols
donc les cachots les dépôt lapidaire
dans le bureau du directeur qui est
permet habituellement au public aussi
manqué de spécial c'était d'avoir
surtout des endroits qu'on soit un peu
cachée du public des inscriptions on
voit pas des graffitis pour les
restaurants c'était plutôt voilà
dallaire dans les cuisines fait dans
l'ambiance d'avoir les bruits de
casseroles les lâches mitis ardeurs des
études
les vidéos sont accessibles sur les
réseaux sociaux sur le site internet
également de l'office de tourisme de
saint germain boucles de seine une série
qui devrait se poursuivre jusqu'à la fin
du mois de janvier
après ce mot de clôture un mot de sport
à présent confinement couvre-feu fêtes
de fin d'année comment rester en forme
malgré tout voici les conseils de notre
coach sportif
bonjour je suis à l'excès barre et
sophrologue et coach de vie ces méthodes
vous êtes vraiment à vous sentir mieux
au quotidien améliorer votre qualité de
vie
et aujourd'hui je vous propose une
nouvelle séance allons-y
vous prenez un manche à balai tiens vous
retirez la brosse et on va faire des
squats
vous mettez bien en position les pieds
de largeur du bassin le dos droit le
ventre gainey et vous allez faire comme
si vous alliez vous asseoir sur une
chaise en arrière en maintenant bien les
genoux dans l'alignement des orteils et
vous montez vos bras à l'horizontale et
vous soufflez en remontant et en
remontant n'oubliez surtout pas de bien
contracté lèche les cuisses et les
fessiers donc l'idéal c'est d'en faire
une dizaine à votre rythme le mieux
sinon vous mettez de la musique de fond
pour vous entraîner un petit peu au fur
et à mesure des séances vous progressez
et vous arrivez en faire beaucoup plus
prenez deux bouteilles d'eau fin et on
va travailler les bras les bis est sans
vraiment cette partie là vous collez les
coudes
le long de votre corps et vous allez
remonter tranquillement
voilà en soufflant à chaque fois le
principe de cette séance et de tonifier
vos bradley musclé muscler vos biceps et
au fur et à mesure des séances vous
allez les affiner si vous multipliez le
nombre de répétitions
donc faites en une trentaine au départ
et au fur et à mesure de votre
progression vous pouvez en faire plus
alors j'espère que cette séance vous a
plu et petit bonus le sport va vous
aider à libérer deux hormones
l'endorphine qui est l'hormone du
antistress du bien-être et la dopamine
qui est l'hormone du plaisir du bonheur
le sport vous aide à vous sentir mieux
dans votre corps à être plus tonique
plus gainey est également donc mieux
dans votre tête
vraiment la sérénité le bien-être je
vous dis à bientôt sur la chaîne
merci à alexia c'est la fin de cette
émission nous refermons cette parenthèse
si on rentrait sur tv 78 en janvier ce
sont vos magazines habituel qui devrait
pouvoir reprendre 7,8 culture et 7,8
sport si on sortait également en
attendant passer de belles fêtes tout en
vous protégeant les uns les autres
à très bientôt
[Musique]